hello everyone let's see okay so I'm
gonna admit this was supposed to be a
free-to-play fun metals talk but then
the more I worked on it the more I
realized I wanted to talk about
misconceptions so it kind of turned into
a free-to-play misconceptions talk I
hope you're okay with that if you're not
okay with that you can yell at me later
so the first misconception I wanted to
talk about is oh and actually you guys
may not know I my company made triple
town Alpha Bear Bushido Barre we just
released alpha bear - we made a game
called realm of the mad God those are
all free-to-play games
some of them reached huge audiences most
of them did not make all that much money
we're trying to get better at that I
think we've finally gotten a little bit
better at that
so anyway okay free-to-play
misconceptions so the first one is
people will donate nicely people will
donate to you if you just ask nicely and
take all the free-to-play stuff out of
your game I hear this all the time it's
a really common misconception
you'll hear it most particularly from
like the vocal minority in any game
they'll just say if you would just take
out all this free-to-play crap we would
just give you money we actually tried
this many many years ago because we like
to do these kinds of experiments and it
failed miserably we made basically no
money I know lots of other Indies have
tried it virtually all of them have also
failed there are like one like in a
million examples we're like they
actually make good money taking
donations and that ends up fooling
everybody please don't do this
like don't assume that you can basically
do no work to make money and just ask
for donations and you'll be fine people
give donations because they see like a
picture of a starving child and their
Facebook feed or because their friend
has cancer those are the things that
cause people to give donations they
don't give donations to you because your
game is fun like that's that almost
never works so please don't do that the
second misconception is that any game
can be profitable if you simply sell
aesthetic items only which are like
items that make you look good or like
show you dancing or whatever and not a
functional benefit in any way and that
obviously is a misconception as well it
depends on the game so in particularly
depends if it's a multiplayer game like
if you have a multiplayer game where
there's a lot of person-to-person
interaction people can see your
character doing certain things then yeah
makes perfect sense you can show off for
other people you can dress nicely for
other people you can do a dance move for
other people so it makes sense to buy
stuff when you're in a single-player
game where nobody can see you it doesn't
really make sense to spend a lot of
money on aesthetic items it can work I
mean it's not like not you know
these are all like sort of general rules
right there I'm sure there's an
exception that proves the rule somewhere
but for the most part it's a really bad
idea to make a single-player game and
then try to make all your money selling
aesthetic goods in general even in
multiplayer games like in our upcoming
steam Birds excuse me our steam Birds
Alliance game which is based on an MMO
we made called realm of the mad God
that's a highly highly real-time
multiplayer game in theory we could make
money selling only aesthetic items but
we also sell functional ones that are
designed not to make it easier to win or
to like beat other people but just to
make your game playing experience more
convenient like we'll sell inventory
storage so you can like if you want to
be a pack rat and save more items you
don't have to it makes but it makes the
game a little bit more convenient a
little bit more fun if you can be a pack
rat and store more stuff so we sell you
that and that sells really really really
well even though it's not a pay2win item
so in general I highly recommend not
deciding that you're just going to sell
a set of goods unless you have a
multiplayer game that can really support
like really potentially support that and
even then be aware that for the most
part the games that make a lot of money
doing that tend to be these sort of like
mulch massive cultural phenomenons like
League of Legends and like in general my
argument is if you're betting that
you're gonna be the next League of
Legends like maybe you have an
overconfidence problem that's kind of my
way of thinking about it so the next
misconception that you can divide gamers
into either their hardcore
or their casual I think this is nonsense
and in fact I think almost every every
bucketing nowadays is harmful like I'm
not a fan of another bucket of saying oh
people in the United States have
different attitudes about free-to-play
than people in China like sometimes yes
sometimes no it depends on the genre it
depends on the target group that you're
you're targeting so no in general no to
all this stuff
and let me give you a concrete example
of where this might break down if you
look at the like the word game audience
which is something I'm very very
familiar with you might say oh okay
that's that's clearly a casual audience
right like it's mostly women like a
majority women who play them more adults
than than kids on and on and on that
must be a casual audience so what are
the stereotypes we have about casual
gamers they don't like complicated games
and they don't like competition totally
wrong
wrong Scrabble in particular and words
with friends in the modern incarnation
has basically trained generations of
word gamers to lust for blood like they
want to crush the competition it's
amazing how much they want it and so we
make single player word games and we
know for a fact that it's hurting our
retention we get feedback all the time
from people who are like I love this
game but I would love it so much more if
you had any sort of competition in it so
right now we're working on putting a
tournament feature in alpha bear 2
because these people want to compete
including you know whatever stereotype
you want to conjure up the 50 year old
you know 60 year old grandma you know
who only plays Scrabble like she likes
beating people so you know don't don't
fall for this trap of like people are
hardcore people are casual or like it
just focus on on who it is you're trying
to serve and try to understand them
better the people I'm trying to serve
for alpha bar 2 are people who like word
games and cute things and those people
happen to like competition also in many
cases I don't call them casuals and this
by the way is a great example of this
it's one of the few screenshots I have
in here this is a game called love Nicki
which was hugely hugely in inspiring to
the people in our studio because a lot
of developers who we respect designers
we respect we're telling us you cannot
make a complex a complex RPG for your
target market you just can't it won't
work you need to keep it super simple it
needs to be easy to learn hard to master
I'm sure you've heard that a million
times it's just gotta be easy to learn
hard to master and you have to let go
with a candy crush style monetization
you can't do anything more than that you
want to do puzzle and Dragon for casual
gamers you're crazy this game for those
of you who aren't familiar with it is a
game about acquiring clothing and then
having dress battles like you that's
what you do you you like you have
dress-up battles I I cannot tell you how
amazing this game is to me it is so
complicated there are so many currencies
and affinities and various things that
play into whether you're going to
succeed in a battle and this game is
played as far as I know I don't have all
the details because they're not made
public but like as far as I know the
audience is overwhelmingly female pretty
broad in terms of age range
it makes a ton of money it doesn't make
any sense
if you follow the whole stereotypes of
like what a casual gamer is willing to
tolerate like it makes no sense
whatsoever but this game is really
successful and the fact that it was
successful gave us some gave us the
courage to make a fairly complicated
meta game in alpha bear to I don't know
if we would have been willing to if we
didn't know something like this existed
so anyway take that for what it's worth
another misconception there's a few
lucky developers who can rely on primo
featuring by Apple and Google to succeed
they don't really need anything else
aside from making their good game that's
no longer true either it used to be true
and I'm speaking from experience we've
been very lucky as a developer
everything we've ever made has gotten a
really great feature by at least Apple
or Google and often times both but to
put this in perspective when alpha bear
one came out not that long ago we got in
the first few weeks after it was out a
million downloads and that was with one
really good feature in one OK feature
when bi should be shooter bi came out
the same thing over a million downloads
in the first few weeks when alpha bear 2
came out which was just a couple months
ago we got better support in terms of
overall support like both platforms
supported us very strongly which isn't
always the case and yet we only got a
few hundred thousand downloads in the
same time period that's with the best
feature we could have asked for we
literally could not have asked for any
better from either side it's just the
nature of the beast things have changed
the market is more competitive now that
the store the the Google Play and the
App Store themselves have have have
fundamentally changed in a few different
ways and you basically cannot rely on
features to be a success anymore you
have to at the end of the day and I
think you know Mike was talking about
this earlier on his panel you have to
have an LTV that enables you to play the
user acquisition game you have to be
making at least 50 cents a dollar per
user on average and if you you know the
number depends on the nature of your
audience and you know the cost of
acquisition for users in that audience
but the bottom line is if you're not
making a decent amount of money per user
you're going to fall flat this has been
a very hard realization for us as a
company we've always been really really
focused on just trying to make the best
game we can and not worrying too much
about the money and then hope
that will be rewarded for it and that
doesn't work anymore so basically almost
all of our effort now an alpha bear - is
going into trying to raise up the LTV of
our users which is not to be perfectly
honest the most fun part of game
development at least not for us but it's
that or die and so we're trying to
figure out how can we do that kind of
work and still enjoy what we do for a
living and there are some creative ways
to do it like so in alpha bear tube for
example you can get rewards for watching
ads in this mode called TV time and when
you watch those ads your avatar and his
companion dock bear sitting there and
they literally crap all over the ads
that you're watching like they make they
have like critical commentary about it
and like that made me feel better like I
almost don't care if like our users like
it although they do by the way it made
me feel better about it so you know
whatever it takes
figure out what makes you feel better
about monetization and then take it
super super seriously because if you
know you're gonna fall flat
so another misconception with compelling
enough content and IP you can sell
content packs to succeed and that's
really all you need to sell mmm that's
mostly cost - so I'm sure all of you
guys remember Mario run it's like Oh
Mario is finally coming to mobile oh my
god it's gonna be an enormous success
how can it not be an enormous success it
was enormous success it turns out or at
least it wasn't a big enough success
that Nintendo's willing to do something
like that again it's really hard it
turns out to get people to pay just for
like a content like what they see is a
Content pack I don't fully understand
why to be completely honest with you
I've not spent enough time thinking
about it to really understand it but
it's not the most successful
monetization scheme it's one of the
easiest ones which is why it's so
tempting for developers to do it it's
like oh sure like I'll make 300 more
levels which I had I can have a Content
10 team do in a month or two and then
I'll put them out there for 10 bucks and
so you know because it's so
straightforward it's very tempting it
doesn't send tend to work there are
exceptions that again that prove the
rule but it doesn't tend to be the most
successful model so be wary of this one
another misconception players will only
tolerate opt-in ads this is by the way
miss cups a misconception that I had
until very very recently it's false but
it's false in the same way a lot of the
things I've been talking about is false
it's false depending on your audience
there are some audiences for which this
is almost certainly true my guess is
that if you tried to make a game like
fortnight and you put in forced
interstitials into it that you would
fail miserably because my guess is since
fortnight users are not accustomed to
that they would be furious with you
they'd be like why what am I going to
play this piece of crap that forces me
to watch ads when I can go play
fortnight but on the other hand if
you're trying to make a word game like I
was with alpha bear - well let's go look
at what the number one word game is the
number one word game and Google Play
currently is again called word escapes
Oh interesting after almost every level
it's making me watch a video ad what the
heck and they're still number one and
apparently they're doing they have a
great rating and they're making good
money so even though I knew that I
couldn't believe it
like I just could not internalize the
fact that forced interstitials would be
okay because I personally dislike them
so much and so we launched without them
we didn't have them in the game and then
we were disappointed after a ton of work
on rewarded video like we spent weeks
and weeks trying to make our rewarded
video like the TV time thing that I
mentioned earlier we spent weeks and
weeks trying to make that compelling and
it didn't really work out we had some
views but not is not nearly as many as
we needed to survive so finally some
friends of mine hit me over the head
hard enough and they were like you
really needed to try the forced
interstitial fine fine okay but even
then we were so worried about it that we
did an a/b test we weren't willing to
just put them in the game so we had some
users in the a/b test seeing
interstitials after basically every game
and some users seeing them very rarely
so now I can tell you factually cuz they
be tested it there was zero difference
in retention like literally zero none
the people who saw them all the time
were tamed just as well as the people
who didn't who didn't barely see them
and then I'm interestingly enough we
didn't have a control group where you
didn't get forced interstitials at all
just because we were worried about
dividing apparati it's too much but we
compared our pretest retention to our
post Reds post-test retention at most
maybe we lost like half a percent
retention it's not like it was it was
meaningless like so long story short for
our audience at least forced
interstitials were completely fine and
helped us make a lot more money like am
i saying like please don't leave this
lecture and see like and think David
Eddy said put force interstitials in
every game
absolutely not figure out if your
audience is okay with them and then the
next question is even then maybe you
don't want to do it maybe you can find
some other way to make money
without them but if you can't if you end
up in the boat we were in where we were
like crap no one's watching our ads and
we already spent weeks working on this
maybe some other tips moving on from
misconceptions this is just a brief one
it doesn't really actually have that
much to do with free-to-play but I
really want to mention it because it's
that important we use a service called
play test cloud which is a place where
we can upload an apk and then we'll get
a video back of the person playing our
game and we can see what they're
touching and they're actually speak what
they're thinking as they're doing it so
like if they get confused they're like
I'm confused right now what's going on
you can you know exactly what's going on
in their head
it's a godsend it's so unbelievably
useful I don't know if you have other
way it's like if you by some miracle
have access to like a great play test
lab great I mean obviously use that and
of course I do things all the time even
with stuff like this
I'll like go to neighbors and watch them
play and things like that but I cannot
tell you how useful it is particularly
in how hyper-competitive the
free-to-play market is today your first
30 minutes to 60 minutes of gameplay
have to basically be flawless because
that's what you're competing against
you're competing against you know
companies that have flawless 60-minute
experiences because they have infinite
money and can do that they can tune in
tune in tune so and I don't know of any
other way to get there aside from using
a service like this for a company like
ours I mean we don't even have an office
I don't have anywhere to invite people
to do play testing so this thing is a
godsend for us we will constantly be
surprised by what by what people are
confused by I mean alpha bear 2 was not
all that different in the first 30
minutes from alpha bear 1 and we were
still shocked at the number of things in
alpha bear 2 s first 60 minutes that
caused people to freak out and get
totally confused
so anyway highly recommend checking it
out if you don't already have a place
testing solution second thing and this
is more specifically for you player I'm
back to being on topic awkward walls can
be surprisingly effective so I don't
know what you guys and of course an
offer wall is the like hey it pops up a
list of games you download them you get
some free coins in my game I my first
experience with offer walls was several
years ago I thought they sucked like
they had all kinds of technical problems
they tended not to work well they didn't
make me all that much money it wasn't
worth a headache so I kind of had this
idea that offer walls were terrible and
then I had a couple of friends with
alpha bear to tell me look they've
gotten much better you should try it and
I was like ok fine twist my arm
and so we spent like six weeks or
whatever I don't remember the amount of
time was probably more than that like
trying to make our rewarded video
awesome and we put this in in like two
days
when we put no effort into making it
compelling we like buried it in like the
store menu and like that was that and it
makes as much money as the rewarded
video does like even though I put no
effort into it whatsoever which is kind
of both wonderful and horrible but you
know that's game development so so if
you have written off off for a while
it's like we did you might want to check
them out they can actually make a decent
amount of money and they don't seem to
be as sucky as they used to and then
lastly and this is probably the most
important tip I'll give you is that I
think it's vital that if you're planning
on borrowing elements from the meta game
of a free-to-play game that you've been
inspired by you have to play it for
months before you do that this is I've
actually talked too much of a I have
some friends who are consultants like
for a living they just give advice to
other people on free-to-play game design
and several of them have told me this is
one of the number one mistakes they see
their customers make which is why I
wanted to close my lecture with this
I've noticed this myself too you'll have
someone who'll be like oh yeah I played
you know I'll mention a game that I've
actually played a lot and really enjoy a
Star Wars Galaxies of heroes I played it
for a week I thought it was awesome I
really like what they do with whatever
fill in the blank we're gonna put that
in our game well Star Wars Galaxies of
Heroes is a game that evolves
tremendously over months of play if
you've been playing it for a week you
have literally no idea what you're doing
like you cannot copy that game
effectively you cannot copy a piece of
it effectively you may for example see
where they you know it's like oh okay
there's three places in the game where
they sell things for hard currency that
must be where they get all their revenue
maybe or maybe those things those three
things are actually not really that big
a deal maybe there's a fourth thing
coming four weeks from now that you
haven't even unlocked yet and it's
actually we're mortal majority of the
revenue comes from but you don't know
because you haven't gotten to that point
in the meta yet this is less of an issue
for games the more simple games out
there like the hyper casual stuff that
tends to be pretty straightforward but
particularly for things that have like a
fairly complicated meta game like love
nicky for example that i was mentioning
earlier
you just can't you
we can't play that game for less than
several months if you really want to
deeply understand it does not matter how
smart you are I worked with some really
smart people a lot of them were super
confused by how these games made money
until they played them for six months
like you have to do this
III please if nothing else you remember
from this lecture remember this like and
the thing is that I've heard a lot of
people saying when I tell them these
things these kinds of things but I don't
like it enough to play it for that long
it's like why are you making a game like
that then what do you what are you
thinking like don't make something that
you dislike so much that you can't bear
playing it like that doesn't make any
sense you're not gonna do a good job
right so seriously like either decide
you're going to find a way to like it or
move on and do something else but that
is the worst excuse I've ever heard for
like doing a half-ass job of copying a
feature out of some other game and I
hear it a lot actually and by the way
the reason I included these screenshots
is because this is just showing the
event system from alpha bar to the
screenshot that says lip teehee it is
basically the entry like you can that's
the sort of entry portal to one of our
events and then the screenshot on the
right is a bundle it's like it's a
bundle designed to help you succeed in
that event that is something that I was
was directly inspired by the way they
monetize events and Star Wars Galaxies
heroes it's been hugely successful for
us like we've made quite a lot of money
with this specific feature I don't think
I would have thought of the specific
implementation without having played
Star Wars Galaxies for I mean I've been
playing at this point for over a year
but I had to play it for many months to
to really to really put that together so
so it's worked out very well for us I'm
pretty confident that I would have
screwed the pooch on this if I had only
played the game for a week yeah and I
think that's it thank you very much guys